(upbeat piano)
- [Narrator] 30 miles northwest of Seoul,
there is a city in Korea
dedicated to all things books.
And this gentleman has been
working to save a piece
of the country's printing heritage.
- [Narrator] Okay, so
letterpress printing is when you
push raised metal types into the paper.
- [Narrator] And how does it work exactly?
- [Narrator] And Korea
actually has a long history
of developing printing techniques,
including the letterpress,
which is usually credited
to Johannes Gutenberg of Germany
who introduced printing to Europe.
- [Narrator] However, in
the ’80's, a new technology,
offset printing, took over
as the industry standard.
And while letterpress may not make sense for
most printing today, Park has found those
who appreciate it as much as he does.
(upbeat music)